everything in this world sooner or later
comes to an end
the planet will live on is no exception
at a certain point
all its natural resources are going to
be depleted
the only issue that the humanity will be
concerned with
will be the search for potentially
habitable planets elsewhere in space
and even today we have a short list of
suitable candidates
as a rule objects within the habitable
zone are located tens or hundreds of
light years away from us
but quite recently scientists have come
across one more exoplanet which is
unprecedentedly close
4.22 light years away
the object is near the closest star to
our solar system
and its name is proxima centauri b
[Music]
the location of this exoplanet would be
known to many or at this point in the
video would be guessed by many
it is the triple stellar system alpha
centauri
the system is made up of three
components interestingly
two of them are seen as a single object
which is also one of the brightest dots
in our sky
these two are alpha centauri a and alpha
centauri b
as for the third component alpha
centauri c
it is a very dim red dwarf and it was
this third humble one that caught
astronomers eye
the first two components are located
quite close together
while the third one is barely visible
that is the reason why the system is
often referred to as a single star
alpha centauri never quite leaves the
horizon and can be easily seen with a
naked eye in such
places around the world as buenos aires
in argentina
or sydney and melbourne in australia
the first two components of the system
are very similar to our sun in their
properties
alpha centauri a for example was the
first star whose atmosphere was directly
observed
as a result a thin cold layer was
discovered
and this is one of the similarities with
the host starvar
earth the age of the alpha centauri
system is estimated at six billion years
which is essentially one and a half
billion years more than the age of our
sun
the a and b components follow an
elliptical orbit around the common mass
center
and their orbital period is 79.91
years as for the third component of the
system
generally referred to as proxima
centauri it is located about .21 light
years away from either of the two stars
and it takes it about half a million
years to complete a full orbit around
them
proxima centauri is 4.24 light years
away from the
earth or 270 thousand times further from
us than the sun
is following some calculations it was
concluded that its actual diameter is
about seven times
smaller than that of our sun and is just
one and a half times bigger than that of
jupiter
like many other red dwarves this is a
flare star
and its luminosity dramatically
increases several times in the course of
its flaring up
this may well be indicative of the
object's impressive age
proxima centauri was spotted back in
1915 by the astronomer robert inns
who noticed a star moving in a way
similar to the other two objects in the
system
that is how he came up with a suggestion
of its name proxima centauri
which literally translates as the
closest
in 1998 the spectrometer on the hubble
space telescope registered a planet half
an astronomical unit away from proxima
centauri
but investigations that followed failed
to confirm the discovery
only on the 24th of august 2016 was the
european southern observatory able to
confirm that there was an earth-like
planet in the habitable zone of the star
it was then given the name proxima
centauri b
first real evidence of this planet's
existence was provided by a group of
scientists headed by mikotumi
an astronomer from finland in 2013 when
they were going through archived data
from two spectrometers
namely harps and the ultraviolet and
visual a shell spectrograph mounted on
the vlt
the very large telescope in order to
confirm the possibility of discovering
the exoplanet
in january 2016 a campaign was launched
by the european southern observatory
and was given the name the pale red dot
several months later
on the 24th of august 2016 the existence
of proxima centauri b was officially
confirmed by a team of scientists headed
by the spanish astronomer guillermo
glades scude and announced by the
european southern observatory
the planet was detected by the radial
velocity method
also known as doppler spectroscopy it is
an indirect method of planet detection
where periodic doppler shifts in the
spectral lines
allow one to say whether there is a
planet orbiting a star or not
proxima centauri b proved to be the
closest exoplanet nearest to us
it is located 7.3 million kilometers
away from proxima centauri
and its orbital period around its host
star is completed within 11.2 earth days
but even though it is comparatively
close to its star
the latter is quite dim and the planet
receives just enough heat for the water
on its surface to remain in the liquid
state
rather than turn into perennial ice
the minimal mass of proxima b is 1.27
that of our earth
following the assumption that the
planet's rock composition and density
are identical to those of the earth
its radius must measure 1.1 that of our
planet
the light received by proxima b from its
parent star
is 65 of that received by our earth from
the sun
the steady-state surface temperature is
234 degrees
kelvin or 39 degrees celsius below zero
a couple of years ago this twin of our
earth's would make for a sensational
scientific discovery
and would be assumed to almost certainly
be populated by living organisms
but had it been the case and had life
forms been discovered on that planet
the video on our channel would
definitely bear a different title
as it is at this point scientists cannot
say for sure whether the planet is
actually habitable
according to today's estimates since
proxima centauri b has supposedly no
magnetic field
it receives 60 times more high energy
radiation and 400 times
more x-ray radiation than our earth
in theory these figures admit of a
biosphere where biological fluorescence
is a protection mechanism used to shield
against ultraviolet radiation flares
this phenomenon is known to be
widespread among some species of coral
polyps or anthozoa
and is also to be observed on exoplanets
orbiting active stars
however just a year after the planet's
discovery
a disconcerting event in the history of
the planet destroyed all hopes so
cherished by scientists
in march 2017 a powerful flare on
proxima centauri was registered by
astronomers using the atacama large
millimeter array radio telescope
the host's star's brightness intensified
a thousand times and stayed that way for
10 seconds
proxima centauri b would have
experienced an overwhelming amount of
radiation from this flare
and if there had been any biosphere on
that planet this event would have wiped
it out completely
scientists believe that if flares like
that occur regularly
they would have completely stripped the
exoplanet of its atmosphere
thus rendering the surface absolutely
uninhabitable
it's worth mentioning here that
radiation endurance of microorganisms
like denococcus radiodurants
allows us to foster hopes that
hypothetically life may yet develop on
that planet following a course of
evolution of its own
this isn't the end of the proxima
centauri systems story yet
in 2019 astronomers from the observatory
of turin
announced the discovery of another
exoplanet candidate in the star's
vicinity
the object was dubbed proxima centauri
sea and may hypothetically boast a mass
at least
six times that of our earth alpha
centauri is currently seen as one of the
first
destinations for interstellar flights in
the future
even in 2016 preparations for the flight
of a nano satellite driven by laser
sails to alpha centauri were announced
to be in progress
the flight time to the closest star was
estimated at 15 years
the name of the project is breakthrough
starshot and apart from reaching its
planned destination it has one more
mission
scientists plan first and foremost to
prove the feasibility of the concept
flights like that are based on
of course now it is too early to say
anything
many would argue that there cannot be
life on other planets as too many space
factors need to neatly combine to
provide
favorable conditions most scientists on
the other hand
refuse to passively resign to this and
so the search for exoplanets doesn't
cease
sooner or later telescopes will get
advanced to such a point that it will
take us just a casual peek through one
to be able to tell if there are any
developing life forms on a given planet
and all mysteries of exoplanets will be
effectively dispersed
and if we really discover nothing with
these extra powerful telescopes
the only thing for us to say with any
certainty will be how lucky we are to be
inhabitants
of our earth
[Music]
you